oh remember remember that guy tony we
went to high school with who ran around
the
the uh the the you know everyone telling
me everyone who's a novelist i saw him
scooping ice cream the other day you
know
i was watching an old interview with
jerry seinfeld i think it was with
charlie rose and he said something to
the effective he knew when it was right
to eventually
leave the show and to stop being a part
of it and he said if i leave now meaning
stop the show the audience will have
this thing where they will never have to
say it was good and then it started to
run out of gas
how does a writer know for their project
or their scene even
that okay i think i should stop now
because if i keep going then
they're going to be like yeah
this this kind of ran out of gas for me
yeah it's interesting i i mean i've i
call it keeping everyone in the room as
long as possible uh and i know and uh
and just because we're always trying to
avoid conflict as humans it's hard
sometimes it's even harder to keep our
characters in scene when the conflict is
just rocking
um and let it let it play out and then
so i think what i think it's more
important to let it play out
and then get them out to the next scene
of okay that happened
and since that happened
now
this is going to happen and how are they
going to get out of that situation
um
so yeah i think that i feel like that's
that's for scene work but if you know if
i was seinfeld i would have taken the
money and said what 5 million an episode
let's go 10 more seasons um you know but
i'm not but he's a stand-up comedian
he's not a he's not a you know at heart
so like kind of like like i get that i'm
a novelist at heart so
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna kill the
novelist in me to make a tv show work
he's not going to kill the comedian in
him to make
next season i guess
sure but in the reverse you you had a
screenplay that you were working on
during this lockdown and you wanted to
extend it and do it in novel form so
there's been a reverse too where you
realized it sounds like you weren't done
telling the story
and you wanted to tell more
yeah i don't know if yeah i it just it
doesn't feel finished
and i think
it was just it's it's weird but it was
like speaking to me too much
it just kept speaking to me and i just i
kept seeing it
um
this is how
it's showing itself to me i guess um
which is a
very you know
i i really don't work in the most
efficient means i should have
rewritten the screenplay and
started pushing it around
and trying to you know make it happen
but
um that you know it's i don't know why
i feel like i had to re i have to kind
of re-enter it
um
maybe because i
that i was
doing it as i thought oh yeah this would
be a fun story and it started as a fun
story then it meant something to me and
i guess when it meant when it means
something to me that's when it kind of
like
oh this actually i do need to tell this
this is this is something that
this is something that's personal to me
that i need to tell
and that's when um that's when
i feel like
um
i'm only part of the process and i have
to
i have to do justice
to this thing
i i have to step up
and
be the very best i can be
to what needs to be told
with these characters and
so
what um what you know i'll in
in heavy rewrites i'll really know
what needs to stay and what needs to go
but
i i you know i i do know the story and i
knew i know where everything goes i just
this is when i'm just just for some odd
reason i'm sinking deeper and deeper and
it who knows maybe it's maybe it's just
a book it never becomes a screenplay and
that just everyone laughs at me to the
end and they say well you're in
development and i go i know what that
means
i'm going to it's going nowhere
so
development hell
that's what it means
what's the definition of that
oh that's uh well they get the uh oh
your your book's option oh my god oh my
god who's interested antonio banderas
he's interested oh my god and it's just
like you know like four four four there
was a four people who called each other
and then antonio bandera said
oh interesting and then interesting
became like he's interested and he's
interested became like he's clearing his
schedule and he's clearing his schedule
became like um he wants to talk to you
but not yet
so kind of like a waiting for guffman
type of thing
okay right right yeah yeah and then it
becomes a game of telephone but
you just don't believe anything you just
you just smile and say thank you yes and
then
it's it's a miracle anything gets made
if someone's in that situation what's
your advice to them
in the situation of getting optioned
yeah just enjoy it i mean it's it's
actually a it's actually a nice ego
boost to
have you know maybe someone talked about
you
it's like it's nice in a good way yeah
maybe it's it's an ego boost like oh
maybe someone read your book
it's just like oh that's sweet
i don't it's not even a relative that's
nice
so
it's um
yeah just i just
you know there's development hell but
there's also just that kind of a
gratitude of well some people seem to
care a little bit and
you know if it goes further great and if
it doesn't be working on someone
something else
that's um
it's a story you need to tell so
yeah that's what i was wondering so
especially for someone that
maybe is outside of the industry they're
in another state or country
and their work is being optioned
so they're not waiting by the phone like
a
like someone waiting for their date to
call
who you know like alone you know on a
saturday night oh tommy's supposed to
call and tommy doesn't call so
what else should you be doing you should
be
writing something new writing something
new being with being with your people
and your writers and your writer friends
who can keep you in check you know it's
uh
yeah i
i've done everything wrong it's uh i
went to my 20-year high school reunion
and i um i that's before jesus jerk was
uh that's right when i finished my final
draft of jesus jerk before i started
submitting to agents
and at the reunion i was like i'm a
novelist i'm an honest
just like and
i it was i was the epitome of the stupid
guy because i wasn't i wrote a novel
but no one may ever see the light of day
fortunately i finally found an agent and
a publisher but it was sheer ignorance
on my part
to say i'm a novelist before i have a
book published before i have an agent
just because i have a draft done
and
it could have been the
oh remember remember that guy tony we
went to high school with who ran around
the
the uh the you know everyone telling me
everyone who's a novelist i saw him
scooping ice cream the other day you
know it's and uh and not that there's
anything wrong with that because
probably most novelists need to publish
novelists need to do that anyway
but um
i just learned to uh
to to be a little more realistic with
myself uh and also like kind of
i guess i guess i had a lot of joy at
the time and plus with that scenario
being able to write a novel after coming
out of the jehovah's witnesses and doing
something that was so
utterly
not not frown not
just frowned upon
to to be creative and that's that was my
whole kind of life was just crushing my
creativity
um so to be able it was almost like i i
come out and go i'm a creative person
so
yeah i was johnny suede i was that was
that was kind of the buffoon
um and i'm i'm going to write a book on
one of these days i'll write a book or
an article on everything i've done wrong
in publishing in the film industry so
you don't have to it's just
it'll be probably the largest book i've
written
but you went to that that high school
reunion feeling good and you left
feeling good yeah no one tried to burst
your bubble
no no that's good uh well and i also
found out that they all knew i was a
jehovah's witness i was trying to hide
it at school you know i'd be like
i said i would uh i would wear suits to
school you know when like i found out
that this i found the specials record
the first specials record and they were
mod and they all wore suits and i'm like
i just got to look like that so if i'm
looking like that at school and then i'm
walking around with my bibles and watch
towers on saturdays maybe they'll just
think i'm just walking around
so i didn't i thought i was kind of
fooling everyone at school
um but it turned out they were like oh
no we knew you're a jehovah's witness
but we always thought you were cool and
i was like
there's a lot of revelations to me that
night interesting and do you still keep
in touch with any of those people i do
yeah yes yeah okay and so now they see
that not only did you publish your book
but then you also made the film maybe uh
they probably don't even care right they
get to see that they're you know i'll
i get photos of their grandkids
you know or i'll find out uh
you know one one is a doctor and
he
talked to me about vaccination stuff and
what he's you know
going on there and it's just like
yeah
in the end um they might not be readers
and they might not be viewers and that's
that's the beauty of it it doesn't
matter i always come into it now with
going you know
now i'm just like i assume no one's read
anything or seen anything i've ever done
and
if they have then i'm pleasantly
surprised and i say thank you that's uh
oh it's
people will apologize oh my god i
haven't watched your film yet i'm like
you don't have to don't worry about it
there's other things in life going on
you know there's so
and it's on imdb
you can you can watch it uh it's like on
amazon imdb they have a
yeah yeah yeah it's on amazon it's on
prime and um yeah i don't know i haven't
i i think it's someone said it was on
youtube for free so
i guess the distributor put it on there
for free which
i have no i have no uh
what do you call it i have no authority
on that on that end of it i just so yeah
it's out there people can watch it sure
yeah and there's the dvd too i i i have
the dvd i haven't even opened the
wrapper yet it's just like oh okay
it's uh yeah it's like the bottle of
champagne you just want to put you don't
want to you want to open it uh i don't
even know where it's at in my house i
was uh when uh when the giants went to
the world series and tim in like 2010
and 10 lives to come got like three cy
young awards and they asked him where he
put him and he said he thinks they're in
the they he thinks that they're in his
car
and i thought that was just so like
dumb at the time and then now it's like
oh no i get that yeah it's because it's
about to work it's not about the
it's not about the end it's about the
it's about the middle